this video is part two of a series on
the history of cryptography
if you haven't seen part one click here
[Music]
we left off in 16th century europe mary
queen of scots had been caught
conspiring with a group of english
catholics
planning to overthrow the government she
was discovered
and executed due to english
cryptanalysts breaking her encrypted
messages
at this point in history all ciphers
could be broken by a smart enough
code breaker with the use of frequency
analysis
none of the bells and whistles
cryptographers put into their
encryptions
fooled the cryptanalysts the
cryptographers desperately needed a
better system
and in comes blaise divisionaire
as a french diplomat he had both a
personal
and a professional interest in
cryptography he realized that the
weakness of the current ciphers
was due to their monoalphabetic nature
they only used one cipher alphabet now
vigenere wasn't the first person to
realize this
he was influenced by a number of
thinkers from the past
like batiste alberti the famed painter
and architect
as well as others who had all realized
you could use
two or more cipher alphabets instead of
one and then switch between them but
vigenere took it to a new level he knew
that the more alphabets used the more
secure the encryption
so he didn't use one or two
he used 26. if you remember
there are 26 variations of the caesar
cipher
envisioner used all of them he did this
by creating the vigenere square the
visionnaire square
is a table made up of all 26 caesar
alphabets
each line is made by shifting the
previous alphabet
one to the left using this square the
letters in a given cipher would be
encrypted
using different alphabets so each letter
in the plain text
could be represented by multiple letters
and
every letter in the ciphertext could
also
represent multiple letters making it
completely immune to frequency analysis
so here's how you do it first pick a
keyword
let's go with white we write down our
message that needs encrypting
and we write the keyword over it
repeating it as many times as needed
we then encrypt the plain text letters
based on the letter of the keyword
for instance this m is encrypted
using w so we go to the row on the
square that begins with w
follow it down to m and there you go
this o turns to v and so on down the
line
you can see the strength in the cipher
when you look here
the double o's in troops are encrypted
to two
different letters meaning a cryptanalist
would have
no idea that there were two repeating
letters at all
vigenere published his new technique in
a treatise on secret writing
but surprisingly or perhaps in some ways
unsurprisingly this cipher was not
widely used in the community
cryptographers in europe liked the
simplicity of mono-alphabetic ciphers
and were wary of the complexity of
vigeneres
polyalphabetic one
okay vigenere cipher went unappreciated
for almost two centuries after
he published it but the cryptographers
still
needed something better than their
current approach
so there were a few alternatives
the first were homophonic substitution
ciphers
a sort of compromise between the simple
but weak monoalphabetic ciphers and the
strong but complex polyalphabetic ones
a homophonic cipher used multiple
symbols
for commonly seen letters for instance
the letter a comprises about eight
percent of the letters
used in english so a homophonic cipher
would have eight different symbols for
a this type of cipher because it has
more symbols for frequent letters is
resistant to frequency analysis
every symbol will come up around one
percent of the time
homophonic ciphers were certainly more
secure
than mono-alphabetic ones but they were
still vulnerable to basic code breaking
techniques
because while each letter could be
encrypted multiple ways
each symbol in the cipher would only
ever correspond
to a single letter another example of
strong encryption
before the widespread use of the
visionnaire cipher was the
great cipher used by king louis xiv
one of the most important french kings
in history
the cipher is so complex that i won't be
diving deep into it here
but its biggest contribution was the use
of symbols to not only represent
single letters but also whole syllables
the great cipher was so strong that it
wasn't broken until
1893 200 years after
its invention
now back to the vigenere cipher as i
said
it took quite a while for the
cryptographic community to recognize
vigenere's genius but by the 19th
century
it had caught on and was being widely
used
as was expected the new encryption was
almost impossible to solve
no one knew a reliable way to break it
until an
englishman named charles babbage
charles babbage was an english eccentric
and polymath
he was the type of man somewhat common
in his day
a man who had enough money to live a
life of leisure
bouncing around from one pet project to
the next
he is most known for his contribution to
computer science
having invented one of the earliest
computers a machine he called the
difference
engine his contributions to
cryptanalysis
specifically the solving of the vigenere
cipher
did not use this machine however just
pen
paper and wit babbage knew that the
[ __ ]
in the visionaire cipher's armor was the
use of a keyword
if you could figure out the keyword then
you could break the encryption
what he eventually realized was that the
nature of how the keyword was used
specifically the fact that it was
repeated was the answer to solving the
cipher
he could use this knowledge to first
figure out
the length of the keyword how well
babbage
looked for repeated sequences of letters
in a cipher
you see a repeated sequence of letters
would indicate that it was the same word
or fraction of a word encrypted the same
way multiple times
next babbage would count the characters
between the repeated sequences then
he would note the numbers down and
figure out the common factor
between them in this example the common
factor is
five meaning the length of the keyword
is
five letters all right let's open up a
dictionary and search all the five
letter words
ah well i've just been informed that
there are around
ten thousand five letter words in
english and besides
a keyword can be in any language or it
could be completely made up
so knowing the length of the keyword
isn't enough but it's a start
so we know the keyword is five letters
long what does that
tell us it tells us that the encryption
is using five of these cipher alphabets
and each of these alphabets is just a
basic
monoalphabetic cipher we already know
how to solve those ciphers
frequency analysis charles babbage's
breakthrough
was realizing that any polyalphabetic
cipher
was simply a series of monoalphabetic
ones
so with the knowledge that five ciphers
are being
used we can look at the first letter
the sixth letter the eleventh letter and
so on
as an encryption of its own and using
frequency analysis
figure out the first cipher alphabet and
by extension
the first letter of the keyword once we
do that with all five letters we'll know
the keyword and will be able to easily
decipher the message
unfortunately babbage never published
his findings
and was not given credit for his
discovery only in the 20th century
when scholars were going through his
notes did they realize
he was the first to figure out how to
break the vigenere cipher
the technique was discovered
independently and then published
about a decade later by a prussian army
officer named friedrich wilhelm kasich
and so the technique was dubbed the
kassiski method
and that's the end of the video as well
as this series
this series only covered the first stage
of cryptography
the second stage of mechanical
cryptography
and the third stage of digital
cryptography
won't be covered on this channel at
least not in the foreseeable future
if you want to know more about it i'd
highly recommend
the code book by simon singh which was
the main source for these videos
speaking of if you liked the video
please like it and share it with a
friend
also please subscribe bye